hello everyone my name is Hannah Youssef
and I'm a product manager on Google
compute engine today I will be sharing
with you an overview of our virtual
machine offerings and how they can help
you run your applications effectively
efficiently and seamlessly on Google
cloud I hope that after this session
you'll be able to identify the different
options that are available to you on
Google cloud and that you'll be able to
leverage them to run all your new
workloads on GCP let's get started I
wanted to start with a quick statement
from Robert insulin our Head of Sales
the statement really summarizes one of
our main goals for Google cloud we
believe that your cloud experience
should be easy simple and pleasant the
best infrastructure experience is the
one that shouldn't require extensive
research and analysis before each step
thus we aim to be the easiest cloud for
the enterprise and Google compute engine
is no exception with that in mind we'll
be taking you through the different ways
that we're making our VM offerings
simple and seamless for you at its core
compute engine lets you easily create
provision and run virtual machines on
Google's infrastructure you can create a
VM choose between predefined
or pre-configured machine types or
create your own custom machine shapes
you can also leverage our
recommendations platform and you can
leave a lot of the operational overhead
to us with capabilities such as live
migration you can also automatically
save money with sustained use discounts
and even enjoy deeper savings when you
sign up for committed use discounts our
focus today will be on the first two
pillars of this experience the ones that
are under vm types on this chart so why
is this important it's important simply
because you will see that compute engine
is foundational to almost everything you
do in the cloud it's foundational to the
applications you want to run to the
success of your digital transformation
as well as the modernization of your
data center and your cloud operations
and because of that we believe that your
infrastructure matters this makes it
important for us to make sure that
compute engine is the right decision for
your business when it comes to providing
the right resources in a comprehensive
and flexible way that accelerates your
innovation compute engine provides you
with the right business decisions to
deliver the right resources to your
teams with simple transparent and fair
pricing the tools to optimize cloud
spend and pay for what you use and
nothing more
also the reliability and security you
need to run your mission-critical
applications compute engine also tries
to offer you everything that you need
everything that you need to digitize
your business so that you can choose
your resources based on the business
requirements with the flexibility to
adapt as your workload changes you can
get access to a variety of predefined
and customizable VM families coupled
with flexible consumption models you can
configure your machine types for best
fit and optimal performance right sizing
helps you get the best balance for
performance and pricing and the wide
variety of the M families help you get
the tailored support for your diverse
computing needs our VMs are designed
with all that in mind they are designed
for real-world scenarios so that you can
run the workloads you want in Google
Cloud and take advantage of an optimized
computing infrastructure that provides
you with the right capabilities for all
your application needs and helps you
accelerate your cloud transformation
this can help you get your scientists in
front of innovation and your data
analyst in front of insights and your
mission-critical applications in front
of your works force we do that by
offering virtual machine types that fit
the different types of workloads you
might be running across our offering we
focus on three key pillars that you will
see me covering today the first one is
that our virtual machines will always
offer you leading price performance to
ensure that you are running your
applications effectively and efficiently
and the
are seeing improvements year-over-year
we do that by leveraging innovations
across CPU vendors and also by
leveraging unique Google technologies
that we've used internally for years to
run our own infrastructure we also
realize that your workloads are not
equal
some of them optimized for high CPU
performance while others focus on
high-end memory configurations for
business critical databases you will see
that our offerings are optimized for
these different requirements and they
prioritize the needs of the different
applications the third pillar is that we
know that you don't run on just a
virtual machine it's all about the
end-to-end experience and the end-to-end
capabilities across networking storage
and compute and other capabilities that
make up your infrastructure experience
and because of that the offerings we'll
be discussing today really cover the
spectrum and make sure that you can get
all the capabilities that you need our
VN families our virtual machine types
come in several shapes from January
purposed workload optimized starting on
this chart from the left you'll see that
our general-purpose VMs are simple
flexible and the best set for the
majority of your workloads eetu or our
general-purpose VMs that allow you to
benefit from deep savings up to 30% of
our general-purpose pricing this family
of the ends is great for customers who
do not have application dependencies on
a specific CPU architecture you simply
pick the amount of V CPU and memory that
you want and will provision it for you
we proactively adjust the capacity for
the entire fleet to optimize utilization
and that means that we give you
whichever processor family is available
based on that we enable you to save a
lot by leveraging e to VMs ii vm type
that we will talk about today is the
family of january purpose VMs and to and
entity these are our our most
flexibility M types they offer leading
performance per dollar
the latest sip
architectures from both Intel and AMD
and the wide range of shapes and
capabilities you can simply attach a lot
of other prefers to these VMs end-to-end
entity are the next generation following
n1 VMs offering a significant
performance jump now let's move to the
workload optimized videos compute
optimized VMs are the best fit
VM type for compute intensive workloads
including triple a gaming electronic
design automation and high-performance
computing they are powered by high
frequency Intel scalable CPUs and offer
approximately 40% higher performance
compared to other GCE VMs next on this
list are our memory optimized VMs they
are about the best fit for memory
intensive workloads including in-memory
databases like SMP Hana in-memory
analytics and in-memory cache memory
optimized VMs offered the highest memory
configuration available on GCP and they
can be configured with up to 12
terabytes of memory today finally we're
working on a new GPU optimize the M type
a 2 that will offer the latest GPUs
available and will be available later
this year now let's start going into
these different V and families and let's
understand how they fit your different
application requirements we'll start
with the general-purpose VMs and they'll
start with E 2 for general purpose
workloads that prioritize cost savings e
two VMs offer up to 31 percent savings
compared to N one VMs on both lists and
commitments pricing this makes them the
lowest total cost of ownership or TCO
offering available in Google cloud they
are a great choice for web servers small
to medium databases dev and test
environments and many applications that
don't have strict performance
requirements they offer a comparable
performance baseline to the current and
want the MS for those of you who have
been using them
two VMs are available with up to 16 V
CPUs and 128 gigabytes of memory and
they also support flexible
configurations through custom machine
types that enable you to right-size your
resources some constraints you should be
aware of is that e to VMs run on any
available CPU in our infrastructure
across Intel and AMD they also run
across older and more recent CPU
generations you cannot select your CPU
these VMs do not offer you the ability
to attach local storage or GPUs however
they benefit from dynamic resource
management which is an efficient
scheduling mechanism that enables us to
give you only the resources you need and
leverage live migration to move you to a
server host with more resources as your
application asks for more the Skookum
technology brings you a lot of benefits
as long as you have a flexible workload
that can benefit from these resource
constraints to assess the benefits to
your workload you can look at the
potential performance per dollar
improvements shown on the slides we're
showing here examples of some benchmarks
and how they leverage the e2 cost
savings for example you can see
approximately 30% higher throughput per
dollar for web serving workloads the
same benefits are also available when
looking at benchmarks that represent app
and dev testing for workloads that could
benefit from these improvements it also
offers a large list of upcoming features
that you can look forward to we are
continuing to expand the capabilities of
e to the MS with new features that
include making them generally available
in more GCP regions making them leverage
AMD cpus as well as Intel CPUs in more
locations and also for the first time
offering committed use discounts for
shared core smaller VMs so that you can
even get more economic benefits and
finally we're continuing to look at new
machine types that would expand the
available configurations to
now let's move to enter and entity VMs
these VMs are the best fit for a
majority of your general-purpose work
clothes as they prioritize flexibility
and offer leading price-performance n2
and n3 DBMS are a great fit for your
enterprise applications databases and
many of your web and observing work
clothes they are also our most flexible
VM offering they give you a wide feature
set enabling granular control of your
resources and coverage across
capabilities that range from sole
tenancy to the flexibility to add and
remove storage at any point for example
general purpose and two and n to D VMs
are designed to support a variety of of
workloads by offering the perfect
balance of compute and memory resources
with up to 200 V CPUs and 800 gigabytes
of memory flexibility is really a core
priority and differentiator for this VM
family our VMs our virtual machines
under end-to-end entity enable you to
right-size your resources which is a
great cost saving feature they also
enable you to auto upgrade to new CPU
generations as we launched the latest
architectures in the market this means
that you can simply choose a minimum CPU
platform and Google will automatically
run your VM on the latest CPU
generations you can attach up to nine
terabytes of local storage per node and
you can get the highest networking
performance with 32 gigabits per second
these VMs are also being rolled out
globally across all of our Google
compute engine regions thinking about
the key differences between n 2 and n 2
T VMs you can see an overview summarized
over here n 2 VMs are our general
purpose Intel VMs supporting the latest
second generation scalable processor
from Intel with up to ACP CPUs
they come with approximately 20 to 30
performance improvement giving you
a great price performance benefit over
the older generations n2z are our AMG
based gel based general-purpose VMs they
leverage the latest epic chrome CPUs and
they come with up to 224 V CPUs per node
they even offer you a lower price point
with approximately 13% lower pricing
versus comparable VMs now let's move to
some benchmarks and show you how you can
benefit from our latest general purpose
amps over here you can see a wide range
of benchmarks showing improvements that
range from 25 to 30 percent for most
workload types you can see that n to VMs
show great improvements when looking at
benchmarks like SAP benchmark DB for
example which represents high-end
databases and over there we can see 30%
higher saps compared to comparable vm
types when we look at benchmarks like
chromium compile you can see that you're
achieving approximately 25 percent
improvement in build time a great
example of the benefits that you can see
would enter the amps for many of your
applications now let's look at some
benchmarks for entity as you can see
there are many benefits that we can see
when looking at data management
workloads given the days leverage in
these higher memory bandwidth and higher
persistent throughput which is available
with the larger VM shapes we've actually
seen up to 2x performance improvements
for some workloads like video streaming
which are represented here through the
stream benchmark and they show how this
higher memory bandwidth can be of great
benefit to many of your workloads so in
summary and to end and to dbms offer a
wide range of capabilities and also have
a rich roadmap as we think about the
capabilities that we're bringing so into
these VM types features that we're
working on range from bare metal
instances to higher networking
performance with up to a hundred
gigabits per second we're also working
on bringing you the latest CPU platforms
across both Intel and AMD and you will
see those continuing to come very
quickly to these instance types now that
we've covered the general-purpose VMs
let's move to some of our workload
optimized and families will start with
compute optimized VMs perform a
sensitive and compute bound workloads
come in many shapes and forms they might
be high-performance interactive web
servers triple-a games high performance
computing across simulations genomic
analysis of media transcoding they might
also be applications that have very
expensive per core licensing and thus
would benefit from higher per core
performance all of these applications
have one thing in common they would see
great advantages from leveraging the
higher procore performance and the
fastest CPUs you can give them and this
is where compute optimized VMs can
really supercharge your applications the
computer optimized VMs are one of our
latest additions to the Google compute
engine virtual machine in portfolio they
offer the latest CPUs Intel scalable
processors cascade Lake they offer the
highest frequency per core available on
Google compute engine with up to three
point eight gigahertz and they offer
multiple shapes that go from four V CPUs
to 60 C CPUs they also enable you to
attach local storage if that's needed by
your application and offer you up to 32
gigabits per second networking bandwidth
with capabilities such as Numa aware
performance and higher performance per
thread as well as higher isolation for
sense for latency sensitive workloads
these VMs can offer you a great boost
for many applications looking at how
this can benefit you let's look at some
of the benchmarks over here these
benchmarks represent
both highly interactive applications and
higher performance computing workloads
the results are evident all of them see
approximately 40 to 41 percent
performance improvements this can see
over here in the increase in the average
queries per second and also the decrease
in the average runtime seen under open
foam with these benefits in mind we also
wanted to share with you some of the
capabilities we're adding to the compute
optimized VMs over the next few months
these include bare-metal instances
support as well as an increase in
networking performance with a hundred
gigabits per second coming soon as we've
mentioned for the general-purpose VMs
we're also always looking at the latest
CPU innovations so that we can always
offer you improving price performance as
you utilize some of these vm
capabilities the second family under our
optimized vm types is memory optimized
VMS memory optimized VMS are designed
for high-end business critical
applications and specifically as IP they
are a great fit for in-memory databases
like sav hana in-memory analytics and
in-memory persistent cache they offer
you the highest memory per core
available on Google compute engine and
the lowest price per gig of memory as
well they feature the latest and fastest
memory technologies and come in
different shapes that range from one
terabyte of memory per node per VM up to
12 terabytes per node which is really
enough memory to run your most memory
intensive applications in addition to
the shapes and capabilities of these VMs
they are also optimized for flexibility
and simplicity
for example capabilities like live
migration helps you minimize downtime
even as you're on workloads that require
12 terabytes of data in memory we can
take away a lot
the overhead for operating those VMs
they also come with flexible commitments
across all the memory optimized shapes
so that they can continue to grow with
you as your data size grows a great
example of that is illustrated over here
when we look at some of the customer
case studies for our customers who have
been using those VMs and referencing one
of the testimonials we've seen we've
seen customers with nine terabytes of
SCP data that is growing approximately
at one terabyte per year so for them to
be able to leverage our flexible
commitments and the many sizes we offer
simply means that they can maintain
support for the their data size as it
grows on our platform if you have
workloads that would benefit from these
memory configurations and would benefit
from the memory optimized VMs you also
have a lot of capabilities to look
forward to some of the capabilities that
are coming soon to our memory optimized
VMs include higher networking and
storage performance as well as
additional s AP certifications and of
course newer CPU platforms and
additional shapes so that you can always
right size your VM to the requirements
of your applications and your databases
now that we've given you a quick
overview of all of the VM families and
virtual machine capabilities available
on GC P we wanted to leave you with a
few statements on how to best get
started with these virtual machine types
so for your workloads that would benefit
from the memory optimized VMs we also
have a very rich roadmap that you can
look forward to this includes networking
and storage performance improvements
we're looking at a hundred gig enhanced
networking capabilities as well as new
capabilities under extreme storage
extreme persistent disk that would bring
you the highest storage performance for
these large VMs we're also looking at
more as AP certifications so that you
can run more workloads on these virtual
machines and as always we're looking at
newer cpu platforms as well as
additional shapes so that you can always
right sighs your VM and leverage only
the resources that you truly need
minimizing waste now that we've taken
you through all of our VM types and
Families we wanted to leave you with a
quick guide for how to get started with
these different VM types and these
different VM families we look at this as
a simple three-step process for the
first step consider your resource packs
what are the shapes and resources needed
by your applications how sensitive are
you to specific CPU architectures you
for example need to use something like
Intel avx-512 and need to make sure that
you're running on CPUs that have this
capability do you need to qualify every
new CPU architecture or are you more
flexible in terms of the underlying
hardware after you've thought about that
we would recommend that you start
thinking about price performance which
of your applications would benefit from
higher performance which of your
applications are highly interactive
where you need the shortest run time and
the best latency for example that would
be one category of applications that
would benefit from our highest
performant compute instances like
compute optimize the amps on the other
side what are the applications that
would be a great fit for additional cost
savings over there we would recommend
that you look at VM types like e to VMs
for example that can give you a lot of
cost savings so once you've had a chance
to look at your resource packs and look
at your pricing and performance
hierarchies now it's time to think about
deployment planning as you think about
your deployment plan we would recommend
you start looking at your capacity
requirements and looking at the regions
where you want to be running your VMs
you can also find a lot of resources on
our Google compute engine documentation
pages that can guide you through the
migration process this concludes our
overview of the Google compute engine
virtual machine types introduction today
we hope that it was useful and that you
have a lot of information to get started
with thank you so much for being with us
today that's all for today